-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Republicans yesterday
elected Mike Johnson
the 56th Speaker of the House,
which is crazy
because a month ago,
we were only at 12.
[ Laughter ]
Politico published
a new profile today
about House speaker
Mike Johnson, titled
"55 Things You Need to Know
About Mike Johnson."
55?!
I don't know 55 things
about my wife.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think there are
55 things about Mike Johnson.
What's number 55 on the list?
He's not allergic to cilantro?
[ Laughter ]
Workers at the Capitol yesterday
hung a sign
above the speaker's office
for House Speaker Mike Johnson,
instead of what Johnson wanted
to hang in the Capitol building,
Mike Pence.
[ Laughter ]
Judge Arthur Engoron
fined former president
Trump $10,000 yesterday
for violating his gag order.
Said Trump, "Here's 20.
I just posted
your address on Instagram."
[ Laughter ]
The United Auto Workers
announced yesterday
that the union has reached
a tentative agreement with Ford.
Though Ford still hasn't managed
to reach a deal with Calvin.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Orlando
recently arrested a man
who allegedly
robbed a pharmacy
and demanded bottles
of prescription drugs,
including Viagra.
The robber didn't have a weapon,
but now he does.
[ Laughter ]
Italian Prime Minister Giorgia
Meloni announced yesterday
that she has split
from her boyfriend of a decade
after an audio
recording surfaced of him
inviting a woman
to join him in group sex.
And he would have
gotten away with it, too,
if he hadn't identified himself.
-It's a-me, Mario.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, every now
and then we get criticized
for not doing stories
about international news,
but I think we have
a very nuanced take.
[ Laughter ]
KFC unveiled two new wraps
this week,
including a fried chicken
and mac and cheese option.
And if you eat them both, you
can get a third wrap for free.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, in honor
of Halloween,
select Chipotle locations
will stay open until midnight.
And to make it extra scary,
the bathroom closes at 10.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Before we move on tonight,
I just want to say something.
As you no doubt know by now,
there was yet another mass
shooting last night,
this time in the town
of Lewiston, Maine.
On this show, we make jokes
about everything --
human stupidity,
governmental chaos.
We even make jokes about evil.
But it is exceedingly difficult
to find a way to talk
about tragedy in the face
of events like these.
You really come right up
against the impotence of words.
All I can say
is we are deeply saddened
by the loss of life in Lewiston
and the loss of life in Israel
and Gaza and Ukraine
and countless other places.
We continue to wish for peace
for every community
living under the constant
threat of violence,
which tragically seems
to be every community,
we're going to try to move on
and have a good time tonight.
But thank you so much
for hearing me out.